some people have absolutely cursed
setups whether it's tilted keyboards
insanely close monitors or a lean only
seen at nap time but Quake players used
to have the weirdest setups in Esports
you might be thinking to yourself where
are their keyboards well since the early
days of Quake many players competed with
their keyboards on their lap freeing up
more space for the game's more vertical
aim style this armest position keeps his
forearm and hand perfectly paralleled
with the table and mouse pad which
allows him to aim very level in the x
and y axis and is also a very repeatable
position over time Quake players have
transitioned into a more natural seating
position but there are still Quake ogs
like Rafa who refuse to change it up and
he definitely knows what he's talking
about there is so much Weighing on this
the dual wield is real